Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is my
Flash episode 4 video.
Lots of awesome stuff to talk about, we got
a Felicity Arrow Crossover, Captain Cold and
The Official Birth of The Rogues.
Geoff Johns wrote the episode, the title was
Going Rogue, so anytime they do stuff like
that you know there’s going to be some extra
comic book easter eggs.
Since there were a bunch of brand new people
that just found me this week, hello.
I do Flash videos every week and all the DC
TV Shows.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up.
Starting with Top 5 moments.
Number 5 - The Flash Is Learning To Harness
the Speed Force
The games, everyone telling him he’s not
fast enough, Harrison Wells telling him there
are still things he hasn’t learned yet.
All part of a season long training montage
where he learns to do the really crazy comic
book things.
Like breaking into other dimensions, traveling
through time.
All very possible once he achieves a certain
level of mastery.
Right now it seems like that’s a long long
ways off.
It’s still a little too early to tell how
far into the Flash Rebirth Comic They’ll
go this season.
So I would say we might see him do something
awesome in the mid season finale.
They usually save the big reveals for moments
like that.
I think it would be crazy if they just went
straight from him running fast to traveling
through time so I think he’ll just slowly
start approaching the speed of light.
Maybe not even that fast.
There is a lot of headroom between how fast
he is now and the speed of light.
The traincar save almost seemed like it was
teasing him going faster.
There are mental and physical components to
being able to access more speed force.
So plan on seeing him as he is for a while.
He still needs to get used to the daily grind
of fighting crime.
Number 4 - The Khandaq Diamond Exhibit
It’s Geoff Johns, so of course we get another
major franchise tease.
They did the same thing on smallville.
Khandaq has also been referenced on Arrow.
As far as I know all of the Shazam Family
characters will be introduced in the movies
first.
Then we might get to see Osiris or Mary or
any of the non A-list characters.
They could also show up on constantine too.
Since that’s a supernatural DC Universe
show.
I couldn’t find any direct references to
the diamond itself other than it’s just
a precious artifact of the Khandaq royal family.
Which is and always has been Black Adam.
I can’t wait to find out what he’s been
doing this whole time when they get to that
movie.
If you didn’t know, The Rock is playing
him.
So picture a super hulked out evil version
of superman.
Number 3 - Felicity Crossover
They made a lot of jokes about why she was
there but really I think she just wanted to
see how Barry was.
The first big one was Barry telling Iris crazy
people would troll all over her Blog about
the red streak.
Felicity chimes in and suddenly we remember
that she had the blog up on her screen in
the last episode of arrow.
This is an example of what I’ll call a passive
crossover.
Yes Felicity was an integral part of defeating
the villain.
She became the moral compass for all of Team
Flash so they could figure out how to get
rid of Captain Cold.
Next big crossover is the mid season finale.
I don’t know that this closed the book on
their ship.
The Flash producers have said that in terms
of romantic relationships they want to keep
it to just their characters.
And the same is true of Arrow.
Felicity has all the new attention she’s
getting from Ray Palmer.
So don’t close the door on Barry and Felicity,
but don’t expect it to go anywhere.
One of the funniest things was when shit goes
crazy and Felicity jumps in and does her hacking
montage.
The camera swivels around her like it does
on arrow.
Stephen Amell has his super hero zoom in shots
when he’s putting the hood on.
This is like Felicity’s version of that.
In the context of the show she’s not a metahuman,
but she is on the A-Team.
And once the show acknowledges you as a badass,
you start getting the action movie montage
shots.
So I just laughed a little when I saw they
did Felicity’s Battle Mode scene.
Also, did you notice how she just had a little
desk all set up for her there.
I think that was the desk that Caitlin Snow
was playing the game on earlier.
But I laughed when I saw felicity sit down
at it.
I know some of you asked why she changed clothes
so many times.
Not counting the super hot dress, I think
each outfit was to denote different days.
Like everytime we saw her in a new costume.
It was the next day.
She was staying at a hotel.
So she was probably visiting for a couple
days.
That would also explain her special little
desk at star labs too.
As creepy as it seemed, I think Harrison Wells
line about expecting great things from her
was just foreshadowing.
He knows everyone’s future so he know she’ll
go on to do more awesome superhero stuff.
Number 2 - Meet Leonard Snart aka Captain
Cold
Probably going to go down as the number 2
all time best villain in Flash History.
Not the most powerful, but the most interesting.
That explains why they picked a really big
actor like Wentworth Miller to play him.
They need someone who can play a complicated
villain, like Harrison Wells.
Another great example of a very complicated
character.
In case you missed it they pretty much breeze
over his entire backstory.
Had a dirty cop for a father who used to beat
him and his sister.
Who might appear on the show eventually.
And it drove him to a life of crime.
It’s his encounter with The Flash that inspires
him to become the person Cisco appropriately
names Captain Cold.
Did you catch his reaction when Cisco called
him that to his face.
It was priceless.
Thematically the character is also a good
example of how heroes create their own villains
sometimes.
I’ve said it before, The Flash’s life
when you zoom out to scale is a big causality
loop.
Something very specific happened to turn him
into the Flash.
It wasn’t by random chance and it wasn’t
something that would have happened naturally
without external intervention.
Harrison Wells caused the big accident on
purpose.
In the episode Cisco without thinking about
it, helps to create captain cold.
Without that Cold Gun, he wouldn’t have
been able to fight The Flash.
This will all make more sense at the end of
the season, trust me.
The interesting thing to note is that Cisco
talked about creating the gun because he though
Barry might turn out to be evil.
We know an evil Flash.
So when he does show himself.
They might have to get Captain Cold’s help
to stop him.
Cisco said it himself, the gun is one of the
only things that can stop someone with Flash
Powers.
And as far as we know, there’s only one
gun.
Just remember that, in the comics Captain
Cold has always been a neutral character,
so it’s not absurd to think he could help
out Grant Gustin if it suited him.
He did leave amicably at the end.
He totally could have called Cisco on his
bluff.
and my Number 1 - Captain Cold Forms The Rogues
If the title of the episode weren’t teaser
enough, the same man who brought him the cold
gun brought him the heat gun.
Mick, the character at the end is the real
name for the supervillain Heatwave.
Guess what his ability is.
The tease came before they pulled that last
heist, Central and Keystone City will be the
Rogue’s playground.
So they’ll probably be in more than a few
episodes this season.
And if you didn’t catch it, that motel room
at the end was in Keystone City.
it’s right here on the other side of the
river.
Central City and Keystone City are right next
to each other.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment.
And while you think about that, here’s some
of the easter eggs I spotted.
I mentioned Khandaq and Black Adam, It’s
not so much an easter egg as something to
watch out for.
The colors that Felicity wears are always
chosen very carefully.
It’s like they’re trying to inception
you into thinking about specific people and
sometimes they’re just a barometer for everyone’s
emotions.
Like when things are chill she wears more
neutral colors, or when she first showed up
in the bright colors with the streaks it looked
more like the Flash.
Like her outfit was saying I’m so excited
to talk to you about your big secret.
So during Arrow tomorrow, just pay attention
to what she’s wearing and what that might
say about what’s going on in the scene.
I know all the women in my twitter feed were
going crazy over that dress of hers.
There's a "Hall of Heroes" in the Central
City Museum.
In the comics, the city ends up dedicating
a Museum to Barry...while he's still alive.
Right now their biggest hero is a cattle king
named Bobby McFeely.
The person that made the phone call is the
person in the comics who is curator of the
flash museum.
Captain Cold talking about the Motor Car Diner,
that’s a place from the comics.
when they were playing trivia, the host was
named Oswald Loomis, in the comics, he’s
the Prankster.
He’s appeared in Superman and Flash comics
going way way back to the Silver Age.
One of the groups names on the board was the
Jailbirds, I thought that might be a Prison
Break joke.
Since so many of their actors they’ve cast
this season were on that show too.
I think I mentioned most of the other big
easter eggs already, but if you saw any I
didn’t mention just write them in the comics.
Overall I gave the episode an A minus.
Amazing introduction for a huge comic book
character with an amazing performance by Wentworth
Miller.
Can’t wait to see him back along with Dominic
Purcell.
He’s playing heatwave.
Felicity with Team Flash was great, you get
the sense that she would totally fit in with
their team.
But it’s Oliver who needs her the most,
so she’ll always be loyal to him first.
The only thing that didn’t really jive for
me was the awkward relationshippy stuff.
Like Eddie and Detective West.
I loved that they had a funny bro moment but
I think we need to get to know Eddie more
before we warm up to him.
As the romantic foil for Grant Gustin you’re
automatically programmed to hate him.
And as a comic book fan, I’m just sitting
on my seat every week waiting for him to snap.
The Iris character is still a bit of a mystery.
I just don’t feel comfortable with her yet.
I think that’s because she’s not inside
the group.
Maybe Felicity seemed so much more fun because
she got to be on the inside from the start.
She pretty much figured out what Oliver was
doing on her own before he ever told her.
So maybe Iris will do the same thing.
I feel like keeping her ignorant for too long
will get a little boring, especially for comic
book readers.
That aside, great episode, great rogue episode.
Looking forward to many more.
They haven’t been confirmed for a season
2, but the CW just announced the first episode
of the flash was their highest rated premiere
in the history of the network.
It’s not a guarantee, but yeah, calling
it now.
Season 2 is a go.
So in case you missed it, crazy Marvel stuff
went down this morning.
They announced all their phase 3 movies.
So I added some links to that in the description.
Tomorrow is a new Arrow episode with Ra’s
Al Ghul, so be sure to check it out.
Right now click here to catch up on Arrow
and click here for last week’s Flash episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow!